what is the most inspiring is the people
in this program like you meet people
that
you know
looking to actually
be the best version version of
themselves every day
and it's very special
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community community-driven vc fund in
silicon valley in partnership with
lumitec sponsored by homeward ventures
hippo insurance opposed labs synergy
global hillel at stanford leap
birthright excel serona partners and in
media partnership with c-tech
let's talk about the world of gaming
with roi raz the ceo and founder of
avivo games
roi is an entrepreneur a veteran within
the mobile gaming industry with over
eight years of experience and today he
is the founder and ceo of vivo games he
holds a bsc in industrial engineering
[Music]
um you've done such a you have you had
such an interesting career journey i'm
not even going to try
to to to go over it uh from you know
looking at social
uh social platforms like
and being an area manager for four years
or one of the most inspiring
organizations in israel uh looking at
the leadership at the end this show is
about leadership to to
being co-founder and ceo of multiple
groups that are dealing with the
publication of high quality fun and
satisfying games and most recently in
the last almost three years of vivo
games
working with developers around the world
to take their games to the next level
i did not grow up as a gamer i've had
the conception in my head my most of my
life that those that are gaming are
wasting their time they're killing brain
cells and they're not doing meaningful
things and
pretty recently in the last few years as
the world continues to transition and
consumer behavior continue to shift i've
gotten to different understandings and
and and gotten to understand you know
the different benefits and that perhaps
i was looking at it from a little bit of
an older lens with less education myself
and it's so rui i'm excited to talk to
you about your perspective and thank you
very much for being here
thank you thank you very much i would
love to share from my uh experience and
knowledge about the so exciting industry
in the gaming industry and about all my
uh journey as an entrepreneur
i'm waiting i'm incredible waiting to
share so
so
roy i want to start with this question
of
the morality of games it said to me it's
a it's a it's a crucial question to
understand and it guides this industry
that it obviously doesn't stop the
industry and and i think we both know
why but
you know you're looking at a person like
yourself for four years being an area
manager executive within
which is all about empowering youth
getting them to be better to get out of
difficult situations to make them better
leaders of being a leader yourself and
then we look at the other side which is
being a leader of mobile game studios
and and companies which people would say
is some people would say is not
doing well for society what how do you
think through that what do you say to
those types of people
so i think it's all about first i i read
it it's very different i mean
social impact is one thing uh and uh all
the the activities in hawaii was really
really really meaningful and uh
really
i really like it i enjoyed it so much
and and i felt like i really
making a huge positive impact
uh on the gaming industry or leading a
startup company is
is answering the same meaning in a way
that like first leading a company
is is
to me to re is meaningful in the same
level i mean
i
i i managed to inspire my employees to
motivate them to make a process with
them to help them learn to help them
growth to help them you know reach their
personal goals so
speaking about like you know being
instructor in hawaii and being a ceo at
the vivo games in a matter of like
making process with people
to me it's the same it's even stronger
when in the industry because the
environment is more challenging we are
competing against
huge gaming other gaming companies
um
so
again to me
it's uh you know it's meaningful in the
same level
i can understand that people from the
outside can claim that someone can claim
that you know
working with a youth in the in in the
neighborhoods is uh
is more important um
so i'm i'm trying to combine i'm trying
to stick to
social impacts and um
making a lot of
activities in the in the
you know in the so in the in the
community um
now we as a company also like supporting
a
uh venture or like non-profit
organization called sierra so here we
are supporting them with the knowledge
that we have about the industry and
helping youth
uh
to know better
what is going on in the industry in the
startup economy and
and so
yeah the answer is to combine them as
long as you feel that you get the
meaning
of what you're doing
i think you're you're you know you're in
a good place
i love it and i think this is also we're
going to come back to this a little bit
and when we're talking about the
leadership program that you're doing now
which is also a phenomenal phenomenal
program if we're looking at hyper casual
games and and i i'm not familiar enough
with the industry and i'd and i'd love
to first stay stay 30 000 feet in the
air what are hyper casual games and
where is avivo positioned today within
the worldwide creation of these games
so hybrid casual games are actually
like the most popular genre in the past
three four years
in the
top 30 games if you look at the
mobile app stores android like google
play and apple store you will see that
of the games are
hyper casual games like in terms of
downloads uh if you look at the top 30
so
like it means like about 30 million
new users a day
that
play download and play hyper casual
it's huge number um
the hyper casual genre is actually like
fun simple games with uh literally top
to play games
with quick sessions very satisfying uh
results like that
that like it's it's so easy to
understand and it's like uh
super super super sad it's satisfying
um
i love to explain it in a way that like
it's games that you can play
by holding the device in one hand it's
always on a portrait view and you can
play it on one hand during you are
you know holding the
when you're taking the metro and yeah
like you know you're you're free with
one hand so you have few minutes to kill
hyper casual is a genre for you the
development cycle of this game is also
quick so the production time is fast you
need to act fast uh the games are
heavily based on trends on social media
like tick tock snapchat uh
instagram facebook
so
the trends are are
you know like if you catch the trend
and you manage to execute fast then you
have a
greater or you know greater potential to
to make a heat gain
um
also if i'm looking at the development
complexity versus you know the
development complexity of games versus
the complexity of understanding the
trends where is really the
differentiation here are you focusing
most of your time on understanding
consumer behavior and what's happening
around the world or is it mostly in the
development and making the games
themselves with the best graphics so the
most seamless with the best user
experience
so we are using a lot of technique
a b test techniques in order to
to understand what the trend is so first
we monitor the markets in a
very good way so we can see
everything that happens like every new
game that is published by any of our
competitors um any new trend that's
rising at this very moment so once we
see that there is a trend what we do is
that we run a quick prototype
we test it by
promoting it in social media for example
in facebook we run quick marketability
test campaign and we get a very quick
feeling of like what is the cpi the cost
per install that this game might
generate
so
instead of
working hard and developing a full game
the very first day like you know from
the beginning what we do is running a
quick prototype test it quickly
measure it and take the decision if we
kill it or move forward to publish it
that's the main concept here right
expertise on user acquisition is
essential here like you must be expert
in user acquisition in order to run this
and execute this test like as you know
efficient as possible
are there given metrics that you know
that you want to follow that if you meet
them then they this is considered a good
viral game or good hyper casual game is
this a set metric that you would uphold
every
every um every game that you put out or
does it change between categories in
between games
yeah it's a great question we've had so
yeah sure there is like kpis for
for
like for a hit game so a hit game must
generate
30 cents cpi cost per install in the us
markets or less of course but like you
know
and and think about it it's like
extremely cheap cpi extremely cost cheap
cost per install if you compare it to uh
other gaming genres like you know
in social casino it can be like 15
dollars even 20 dollars cost per install
here we're speaking about 30 cents in
the us market
second once uh the marketability kpi is
met
then the next phase is the product kpi
which are focused mainly on retention so
we're looking on 45 day one retention
22 day three and fifteen percent day
seven now what is tricky here is that
these kpis are really really really hard
to reach really hard to reach it means
that if you think about the industry
think about the developer on the other
side of the world that is working hard
on
creating this game and then you try to
publish the game with with the publisher
i mean it's a given fact that the studio
can't publish it by itself i mean no way
that the studio will publish in you know
without the publisher right so studio
must
collaborate with the publisher in this
case
and the chances to publish are very low
like less than one percent here is the
the opportunity that that we
actually see here in ofo that's
a huge huge amount of developers looking
for a publisher but end up without
publishing their game
the reason
and the reason for this like uh
like the kpis that i destroyed before
are so hard to reach because if you
reach these kpis your games will
generate like millions of dollars
but the thing is i have never met a
studio that told me ray i'm targeting
and i'm aiming only for like you know
one million dollar or more like
and i'm not happy with less
99 of the studios
are very very very satisfying
like will be very very very very
satisfied from from generating 100k a
month or even 10 000 a month
of profit so
in this case
we do look at these kpis that i that i
described before but we have
more uh data on our side that we already
uh gathered and collected based on the
test that we did before
that we know also to to
uh predict
what profits uh
average game will will generate
and we publish also games that didn't
meet the the
cpi kpi
but was closed to reach it or
made it but amid the cpi kpi but on the
product side the retention was lower
and by making some adjustments we know
how to publish these type of games and
generate not making like hits of this
game but definitely make very nice
profits to the developer and to
ourselves so
this is very different approach that we
developed
vivo
to actually answer the huge gap between
the studio needs and the publisher need
i mean we are at this moment
basically the almost the only publishing
house
that look at the statement that comes
that published the games from the same
uh
point of view of the studio like or the
same interest as the studio on the other
side
which enabled us to work with like that
is leading leading leading uh hyper
casual studios worthwhile
really really interesting
this question of ditching a game you
know you've come up with some thesis
you've gone to develop it whether it's
fast or slow
there's an emotional attachment to what
you've done and there's always this
this conversation in your head let's
just try one more thing let's try
something else maybe we can get our cpi
down maybe this will take off
is it a clear-cut thing when you need to
ditch a game or is there some conflict
internal or external to
ah maybe this maybe we should wait a
little bit longer before we're saying
we're not going to be supporting this
game anymore
so the magic word is like ignore gut
feeling we are data driven
it's extremely lovely you know so we
ignore ignore gut feeling and we look on
data and like uh
of course there is like games that are
really really really on the borderline
and you are not sure so in this case
we'll give it another chance because we
we want to be sure that we we we give it
like you know that uh 100 chance to
succeed but uh in most of the cases
they're
it's black or white i mean or it's you
know it looks promising or it's very far
from from being promising
so
so to answer your question
we are follow the data the data what the
data tells us that's what we do follow
follow the data and tell me a little bit
about this leadership program that
you're doing i after you sent it you
sent it to me i took a look and it looks
fascinating and how does that impact the
way that you think through your own
leadership style and leadership methods
so
it is it is very interesting program
which i started
two months ago it's called the hoffman
kaufman leadership program
it was founded by reed hoffmann the
founder of linkedin and professor fred
koffman which is a vp in google and
an advisor for
leading ceos all over the world super
inspiring
person uh he also the author of the
meaning revolution a book that i was
just finished lately
amazing by the way the meaning
revolution book is exactly about how to
manage
and lead a company
with meaning like you know
meaning is the king today to be honest i
mean
and
i can speak about more about meaning but
let's stick to your question so about
this program so
this program
is like the content is in this program
is inspiring uh in a way that we are
dealing with maybe practicing daily like
meditation uh we have breathing did you
heard about wim hof
a crazy
dutch
guy that uh
[Applause]
the iceman exactly the iceman he's crazy
so
the iceman actually uh made me uh jump
into a
ice bath
a week ago and take a stay there for two
minutes inside the ice in a bath so it
was crazy
and and
in order to do that by the way to stay
two minutes in a
you must practice your mind and focus
in a way that you know it's
the best it's the best practice to see
like if you're going out of focus you're
punished immediately you know you you
see on your face on the face of the
person that's staying about that if he's
not concentrating not focused boom in
panic because he see that he's starting
to shake and like he's starting to
freeze and if you are focused about pre
on on your breathing on on like on your
mental uh resilience during this
practice yeah you can stay even for more
than two minutes um
we're practicing uh physical like
physical training like uh i'm running
every day
uh
the daily routine is starting with
meditation
breathing physical practice reading it's
every day it's like a habit that you
practice and uh
and uh follow day by day
uh so this is how inspiring is it in
addition we have a group of uh with a
mentor that like uh helping us to
discuss about like uh specific gaps that
we experienced every week in a different
topic and we raised like uh uh
in relation to the topic we raised like
a gap that we want to discuss
uh
so
yeah and and on top of everything
what is the most inspiring is the people
in this program like you meet people
that
you know looking to actually
be the best version version of
themselves every day and it's very
special to be honest it's very very
special to be
surrounded by or to meet like these type
of people
phenomenal roy
sounds like an amazing journey with some
really awesome insights into hi how the
gaming world works and hyper casual
gaming the complexity and i and i
learned about all the different
intricate details here of how you're
thinking through
games that are
you know that are working that are that
are data driven put out the gut feeling
ignore the gut feeling be focused be
resilient taking from the leadership uh
courses that you're doing but also
taking from the social
the the social good that you were doing
with that that you're continuing to do
and it sounds like just a great balance
all around in a really fascinating
ecosystem that is just exploding away
thank you very very much for your time
and for your energy i look forward to
sharing this with the world and thank
you very much awesome thank you it was a
pleasure thank you very much
[Music]